hey this is super interesting Newsmax is
talking about Tulsi gabbard as Trump's
running mate for 2024 and I have to tell
you
it makes a lot of sense it really does
so you might remember that yesterday
Tulsi gabbard uh on the first episode of
her podcast what what uh fortuitous
timing announced that she's leaving the
Democratic party now really for years
Tulsi had no business being associated
with the Democratic party she was a
um a contrarian reactionary with pseudo
populist right-wing messaging much more
aligned with Maga world than with any
Democrats that I know she now officially
has left the Democratic party and is
becoming an independent and here is Greg
Kelly on Newsmax saying what about Tulsi
as Trump's running mate Tulsi gabbard
she quit the Democrat party today and
did it in spectacular fashion oh the
former Democrat congresswoman from
Hawaii is now in by the way we looked at
the video by by spectacular fashion she
did it with conspiracy theories about
elitist cabals and false claims about
what the left believes dependent and I
believe could very well will be a future
running mate for Donald Trump whoa all
right so she quit on the first episode
of her new podcast take a look
now I love our country our god-given
rights of Freedom life and Liberty that
are enshrined in our Constitution Bill
of Rights are what inspires me
all right she's just warming up you
realize though that statement about the
Constitution a reverence for our Bill of
Rights how this makes her Persona
non-grata in the Democrat Party this is
radical stuff for them actually her
completely reactionary conspiratorial
statements and false claims about
anti-white racism woke and an elitist
cabal are what make her not at home in
the Democratic party now I have to tell
you
it makes way more sense that she would
be Trump's running mate I mean think
about it they're on the same page about
oh uh the the left is all about being
against faith and against religion and
uh they want to be racist to white
people
it makes a ton of sense that she would
be Trump's running mate and that's why
we can tell it never really made sense
that she was a Democrat there was this
vague idea oh she's against regime
change Wars
uh okay
and that made her what special in some
way most people are against regime
change Wars when they agree about what
the regime change Wars are but there was
really nothing else that made her at all
interesting to the Democratic party or
as a Democrat and so I don't think she's
actually going to be Trump's running
mate but she would be much more at home
there uh as a Maga reactionary than she
has been in the Democratic party for a
very long time